about the women
Well everybody's got a chance to talk
I'm gonna shut up and have my Clementine
no I want to know I want to know I want
to learn from you sir you want to learn
from me well I wanted to answer I feel
like it goes for both it's not just one
of the other I feel like it's
self-accountability
women are not accountable for themselves
I agree with you there why just women
though
there's both you're right but Society
punishes men for not being
self-accountable but Society does not
punish women for not being
self-accountable I'll give you an
example if you're a man and you're
arrogant and you think you're something
when you're not trust me Society will
teach you very quickly that you don't
matter when you don't get laid and you
stay [ __ ] broke if you're a chick and
think you're something when you're not
you can run around with your ego still
get dates still get laid still have a
fairly sensible social life society as a
whole doesn't come along and slap you in
the face with realizations if